[MUSIC PLAYING]
MITCHELL: Let me welcome
you all here this evening.
I'm Bill Mitchell.
I'm Dean of the School of
Architecture and Planning.
The occasion this evening that
causes this talk to take place
is the opening of a new space
in the School of Architecture
and Planning that includes
a magnificent recent work
by Frank Stella, the Loohooloo,
made available to MIT
very generously by Elliot Wolk.
We've worked over the weekend to
get it all ready to open today.
And sure enough, things
got finished just in time,
and the space duly did open.
It's in Building 7.
I had to check this just
before I came up here to talk.
It's room 7336.
Am I correct on this?
Yes.
I am correct.
It's 7336.
They haven't put the
number on the door yet,
so I have to be
careful that I give you
the right number on this.
It's not open this evening,
but as of tomorrow,
it will be open to the public.
And I encourage everybody
to come and take
a look at this piece.
It's a magnificent
piece and a great room,
and it will also bring
you into the heart
of the rebuild
headquarters space
for the Department
of Architecture
and the Department of
Urban Studies and Planning
in the School of
Architecture and Planning.
And it also includes a really
interesting, new exhibition
space that we intend to
make very active use of.
So we welcome you
all to that space,
and we very much look forward
to seeing you all there.
Let me make a very brief
introduction to what
we're going to do this evening.
To anyone who's
interested in painting,
or in thinking about
painting, or in the theorizing
of painting, Frank
Stella really,
truly needs no introduction.
So I am going to be brief.
Born in 1936, a
Boston area native,
educated at Phillips
Andover and at Princeton.
For four decades, he has
been producing series
after a series of astonishingly
inventive and thought-provoking
explorations of what
non-figurative painting can be
and can become.
He's had all sorts of
extraordinary twists
and turns in the
directions that he
has taken, confounded
and astonished
the critics at times.
That has been
unfailingly thought
provoking and really
pushing the envelope,
pushing the edges of
what painting can be.
In the wake of the heyday
of abstract expressionism
in the '50s, he began to
produce, as many of you know,
his black paintings series.
This was followed by the
aluminum and copper paintings
and the shaped
canvases, breaking out
of the rectangular plane.
He moved into painted
metal reliefs in the '70s.
Later, huge three-dimensional
pieces in the Moby Dick series
and beyond.
And explorations that's
continued until now
and has given us Loohooloo,
the piece that we'll
be able to see later on.
He's moved back and forth from
rigorously precise execution
to slightly playful
improvisation,
from straight lines
and flat polygons
to the curves with spatial
readings of the exotic birds
series.
He's been an innovator
in fabrication technique
and in the means of making,
of executing paintings,
as you will see later on.
In his Norton lectures
at Harvard a decade ago,
he produced a sustained
theoretical exploration
of the aims and
means of painting
that deserves reading
and re-reading.
We're going to have a
conversation about mostly
recent work.
We're going to sit
over here on the stage
and just talk about the
slides as they come up.
I have to tell you,
it's completely
unrehearsed and ad hoc.
We just looked at the
slides a few minutes ago.
And we're going to
do our best to make
this interesting for you,
but I think it will be.
Just before we
start, what I'd like
to do to give you an idea of
what we've been going through
in pulling this
extraordinary piece of work
into the MIT
context-- we're going
to show you a video of
the work arriving at MIT
and, in particular, some
extraordinarily skillful crane
operators maneuvering
it in through the window
of Building 9.
I saw some of this happening.
I haven't seen the video.
So let's take a look
and see what happened
as this piece joined MIT.
[CRANE BEEPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
STELLA: Thanks.
Is that on?
MITCHELL: Yeah.
We're on.
STELLA: Okay.
I can't resist a blackboard,
so I'm going to draw--
I'm not going to draw, actually.
I'm going to write a few
words on the blackboard.
And then we can start
showing the slides
and go on from there.
They are basically two
questions that I get asked
over, and over, and over again.
One, why did you change, and
two, what's going on today.
Why I changed, I really
don't have an answer to that
except it's obvious.
You keep going.
But what's going on today, which
is a way of talking about what
we just saw in the video clip--
I'd just like to
run by you as simply
as I can the way I see
what's happening, say, now.
I'm not going to define
what the art of the '90s is,
but it's interesting to see,
or at least to talk about,
what's happening and not
just what I'm thinking about,
but really what everybody
else is thinking about.
And it's pretty
easy to explain it
or to make a very
simplified version of it.
And so it really
consists of two things.
And so what you have today
is you have a painting.
So if you have painting--
I know you all know
that that's painting.
But it doesn't have
to be just painting.
It's really art to today.
So because you're making art,
and most of it can be painted
or it could be other
things, it breaks down
into two things, which
is we have literalism--
it's a horrible word,
but it's the best one--
and we have illusionism.
And we used to have
problems like abstraction
and representationalism, but
that doesn't really matter.
I mean, we have
100 years of that.
And it's come now, in the '90s
or at the end of the century,
to this kind of way
of seeing things.
So they don't necessarily
have to conflict,
but they represent two different
polls, or they represent,
maybe, two different ideas.
But they all revolve
around the same thing,
which is that in
order to do anything,
you have to deal
with boundaries--
I don't know why I
like spellings these.
I just like writing
with the chalk--
[LAUGHTER]
--to see if I can spell.
You have boundaries
and you have surface.
And that's what you're going
to see a lot of in the slides,
and those are the kinds
of things that I'm
going to talk about a lot.
What you saw in the
video, you can already
see how much it's about
surface and how much
it's about boundaries.
And you can see that
if it were just what it
is when you see the
back side of the piece,
that would be the literal part.
I mean, that might
be good enough.
It might be a Henry Moore.
It might be a
minimalist structure.
It could be in steel
and be a Richard Serra
and do quite well.
But it has something
else, which is
the painting, which is the
surface that I worked on
anyway.
It's involved with
illusion, or illusionism,
and that's what brings
it back towards painting.
And the literalism
doesn't exclude painting,
but sometimes it's a conflict.
And so we'll go, basically, from
there, looking at the slides,
see how I got to it, and what
other things it leads to.
Basically, what the
conclusion is going to be
or what you might come
to as a conclusion
yourself when we get through
looking at the slides
is that art, in
the end, will pass
through all of these
things-- through literalism,
illusionism, boundaries,
and surface basically.
And it'll end up by defining art
as something that you already
knew it was there, which is
it's going to be painting,
sculpture, and architecture.
So it won't be a
surprise to you,
but that's what
the fine arts are.
And what happens is a lot of
the divisions and different ways
that we have of looking at
things have to do with the kind
of not necessarily
confounding, but they
have to do with people
taking positions in relation
to these things in which they
want to have their own thing
or find that the thing that they
do best being the better thing.
But we're not going to
really worry about that.
We're just going to see
how they can come together.
And we don't know how
they're going to--
I certainly don't know
how it's going to happen,
but you can see in
the work that I'm
doing that they do
relate to each other,
and they do become involved.
I'm not saying that a
synthesis is a great idea,
but you can see at
least-- or I can
see-- that there are
some possibilities
for a kind of synthesis
that would be interesting.
And that's why I change.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
MITCHELL: Okay.
Let's have some slides, and
we can take down the lights.
STELLA: The piece on the left, I
made at Andover in 1953 or '54,
and it's the Brooklyn
Bridge, believe it or not.
And a lot of people think that
I painted the Brooklyn Bridge,
but that was Joseph Stella.
We're not related.
So actually, it's a
kind of opportunity
to sort of lay that one to rest.
When I first came to New
York, a lot of people
said that they were
quite surprised
to see what a young man I was.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, I wasn't that surprised.
I was younger then.
And the picture on the
left is a painting which
is very typical for the time.
It's a kind of abstract
expressionist painting.
It seems to me-- actually,
although it might predate Al
Leslie, some of his paintings,
a little bit that way--
but very much like Motherwell.
Al Leslie, pretty much a
kind of second or abstract
expressionist painting.
But the people that I was
most influenced, probably,
in this painting were
Motherwell and Gottlieb.
And interestingly
enough, it had a title,
and the title came out of
a New York Post headline.
But anyway, that
painting was called
Requiem for Johnny Stompanato.
And I'm sure that no one
here really remembers
who Johnny Stompanato
was, but he
was a hood who came
to an unfortunate
end with Lana Turner's
adopted daughter
when she stabbed
him in the kitchen.
Okay.
We can go on.
That was the last kind
of painting on the left
that I made before I
made the black paintings.
So you can see the transition
from the Johnny Stompanato
painting.
And really, it's a landscape,
and the real change
is pretty straightforward
and pretty simple.
It happened by painting out.
You can see that there
was a structure underneath
and that there was
a painting that was
formed with bands and blocks.
And you can see that somewhere a
frustration occurred and things
were-- and then it
got painted out,
but it got painted
it out in such a way
that it became a whole painting.
And that idea of
painting it all yellow
or painting over the other
painting and making the bands
carry the whole
thing is what made
the black paintings
possible, because then they
were all black.
It seemed to be okay.
It seemed to be a
way for painting.
And again, I don't want
to tie-in too much with--
but if you were to see
the Mondrian show now,
one of the things
about the abstraction
in that kind of painting is
how landscape derived it is.
And this is only a
coincidence to me,
but both of the
paintings that you saw--
although the Brooklyn Bridge
happens to be the bridge,
it's a landscape
kind of painting,
and painting for a
Johnny Stompanato
is basically a
landscape painting,
and this is a
landscape painting.
This is called Astoria.
And it was about the
sunrise in the morning
as you travel on the
subway to Astoria.
The one on the left,
believe it or not,
although it looks like
an abstract painting,
is actually a portrait.
It's a portrait of Carl Andre.
[LAUGHTER]
MITCHELL: How so?
STELLA: These were all--
I did a series of paintings
which were polygons
with the centers dropped out.
And that could be a frame,
and the portrait, obviously,
could go in the middle.
But I knew what Carl looked
like, so I left it out.
[LAUGHTER]
And I did a series
of other people.
I did Leo Castelli and Ileana,
his wife, and all my friends.
It was a group of portraits.
But actually, it was
an interesting thing,
because I did an octagon.
Right after that,
the graphics started
to form images which had
spaces in the middle.
And the one I can think of is
a Chase Manhattan Bank logo
which appeared about
six weeks after my show
at Leo's announcement.
And then that was a
painting done later on,
which is-- again, and
you can see boundaries.
It's become an issue
here in surface.
That's practically
the only issue,
but it's an interesting
way to see it.
And this, in a way,
relates something,
finding a way to deal with
the things that come up later
are a way of looking
to make a space.
Okay.
We can go on.
Sorry.
Well, this gets
into another idea,
which is a way of dealing
with the boundaries
and the surfaces.
But this time, the thing
that's going to be painted,
or the painting, instead of
being kind of self-defining,
becomes something that's
built. And then the painting
takes place on
what's built. So it's
a way of thinking
about the painting
as not so much
marks on a surface,
but as a structure and sort of
building what it is that you
want and then painting it.
But in order for it to work--
the problem with this kind of
way of working and thinking
about things is that it's not so
easy to make the painting seem
that it really--
it has to do something more than
appear to be on the surface.
It's just difficult, that's all.
But it's a problem.
It also has it's kind of
rewards, because it's a way
to be, at least pictorially
and graphically,
dramatic in a
relatively easy way.
MITCHELL: And these are
fabricated in metal?
STELLA: Yeah.
That's fabricated in aluminum,
and the other has fiberglass.
And that's honeycomb aluminum.
And the other thing here
is treating the surface.
It doesn't show up much there,
because it was very shallow,
but the aluminum
was etched first
and then the painting and
then inc and some things
were scrubbed on the surface
to give it a kind of movement.
MITCHELL: Did you ever get them
fabricated in a shop and then
bring them there?
STELLA: Yeah.
This was the beginning of the
surfboard technology, actually,
which ends with [INAUDIBLE].
This was fabricated
in California.
And this is taking
what we've just
seen before one step further,
but there are new elements.
And there's an attempt here
to make the surfaces move,
so they're not just planar
surfaces in relation
to each other tipped or tilted.
It's an introduction of another
degree and level of complexity.
Now, I didn't do these.
[LAUGHTER]
But this interests me a lot,
and the reasons are down there--
literalism, illusionism,
boundaries, and surface,
and even painting and art.
The surface here is given.
On the other hand, it's used.
And it's a very complicated,
very irregular surface.
And on the face of
it, we would assume
that they didn't really care
that much about the surface.
But let's have the next slide.
It's pretty obvious on
the one on the right
when they go to the trouble of
incising and cutting the line,
and it is a tremendous feel
for the surface and the given
things.
There's making and
controlling your own surface
by indenting and
making the relief,
and then there is the use of
the relief and protrusions
that are given by
nature and the surface.
So it only goes to show that,
from the very beginning,
people who know
what they're doing
or care about what
they're doing have
a sensitivity to the whole
scene and the whole situation.
And you have to bring your
own touch to the surface,
but you need a surface
to react to in a way too.
It always helps.
I think there's been a big--
it's not a big
problem, but you can
see that the assumption of being
given a neutral or flat surface
to work on is not such
a great gift, as you
can see from these paintings.
Now, this is something
that we don't have anymore,
and we don't have these kind
of complicated architectural
surfaces to work on.
Again, this is a given
surface, but it's
made much like the
surface in the caves
in Lascaux and Altamira.
And again, it's the
question, or the issue,
or the interest in
surfaces and things
that you can do when you're
given an opportunity.
Things happen when
there are opportunities,
when there are challenges,
and the Roman and the German
are good examples.
And they also serve as
pretty good reminders
that the degree of complexity
can be quite great,
and problems in dealing
with them are great too.
By and large, in this
case, most of the solutions
are what we would
call scenographic,
and we would tend to say,
well, it's decorative.
And those things are all
true, but when there are also
other examples where these
things are taken to heights
in expressive and heights
that are truly great,
and they couldn't be
done any other way.
MITCHELL: Here the
surface dissolves too.
If you're down on the floor,
we have a true [INAUDIBLE]..
STELLA: Yeah.
But I mean, it's hard to find
a place to look at things.
It's hard to know where you are.
I mean, it's also hard
to know who you are.
[LAUGHTER]
But now, having shown
the things that we
saw running through
the paintings and some
of the ideas just tipping over
the top, what happens is--
again, we talk about change,
which is that, at some point,
you take things
from the outside,
and you deal with them
in a kind of ordered way,
or you make a mark or a drawing.
You try to order things.
You try to organize them.
And then at some
point, it's hard
not to be interested
in the things that
happen that are beyond your
control and beyond your,
actually, imaginative
ability, or just any ability.
I mean, for me, this is beyond
my ability to comprehend it.
But anyway, these were actually
done relatively recently,
about four or five
years ago, but I started
on it when I was working on--
actually, when I was in
Eliot House at Harvard.
And I was blowing smoke
rings, and Harriet
had gone back to the city,
and I was there alone.
And they heated up the room,
as they do in all universities,
and then they think
that's warm enough.
They turn off the heat.
[LAUGHTER]
And this was a happy moment.
When the heat was off, and
the air was very still,
and it was still warm enough
blowing the smoke rings,
they started to do
a lot of things.
And they filled up, and I
really could see the smoke
just because I was alone in
the room with just one light
where I was reading.
And blowing the smoke
out, the way they hovered,
and they held, and
then they did what
they did here,
which they dropped,
and they sort of bifurcate.
They make other smoke rings.
And as you can see,
these are photographs.
Actually, the fellow that you
saw in there, Andrew Dunn, who
kept saying shit all the time,
and he was putting things--
was the one who
photographed these too.
But this was almost
as unpleasant
as putting the
piece in the room,
because the black box was
pretty hard to handle.
But anyway, we photographed
these from six sides
in a black box.
And then with the photograph
from each side, we had a cube.
And then with that, we
could trace them, and then
feed it into the
computer, and get-- go on.
I think we'll see some.
You'll get a version.
Oh.
There's another.
Now, this is a continuation.
There's someone else
blowing a smoke ring.
[LAUGHTER]
But actually, it wasn't smoking.
And we're making a piece
of sculpture there.
And I only throw
that in to show you
that it's the interest in
things outside that you really
can't control.
Molten metal is pretty--
that's molten stainless steel.
And you can use it, but you
can't really control it.
Or at least, we haven't
found a way to control it.
And again, the smoke
is the same thing.
It sort of dissipates
itself, so it's pretty hard
to get it to do
exactly what you want.
And so I guess that the
interest of the change
has been in things that have
their own way of doing things
that you can be involved
with, you can participate,
you can look at it,
and you can see them.
You can try to work with them.
You can try to shape with them.
But it's to see if
some of those things
won't give you a way
to sort of spring
out, to get beyond
where you were.
MITCHELL: What kind of
smoke is [INAUDIBLE]??
STELLA: Well, my
smoke is cigar smoke.
That's not smoke.
[LAUGHS]
MITCHELL: [INAUDIBLE]
smoke rings anyway.
STELLA: Yeah.
MITCHELL: [INAUDIBLE]
cigar smoking?
STELLA: No, that's the
porpoise making them.
That's a beluga whale.
But the whale, he--
MITCHELL: [INAUDIBLE]
STELLA: Yeah.
No, the ones before were smoke.
And also it was
his form that led
to the shapes in the
paintings before,
which is the beluga moving.
Okay.
I guess we can go on.
That's the computer's version
of what we saw in the smoke.
It's not exactly those
rings, but that's
one way we could get it.
And then you all know this.
I mean, I'm sure
you're very familiar.
That's just on the computer.
But that's an open
net, and the other
is a solid version of
it, what it would be like
if it were a perfume bottle.
[LAUGHTER]
And that's a painting on
the right, quite similar,
that has the forms.
And there are two
basic forms in here.
There's the smoke ring.
Most of those
drawings are versions
of the computer drawings
of the smoke rings,
and there are
basically two kinds.
There is a net.
And then there are some
two-dimensional outlines, just
drawings.
And then there is some of the
three-dimensional, complicated
ones with all the numbers,
which you all know
are sliced versions of a solid.
And then you tip them, so they
make kind of dramatic drawings.
The other thing are the dots.
So it was a combination
of the smoke drawing
and dot the colored
images in the background.
And those are enlargements
of four-color printing dots,
actually.
And on the left, there's
some very unsuccessful,
but sort of what I'm looking
for or one of the things
we were looking at.
I don't know how far we'll get.
It was a question of making
the dots three-dimensional
and, of course, making the
smoke rings three-dimensional.
And those dots are
three-dimensional dots,
but they're derived
from lumps of clay,
and they're scanned, and
then put in the computer.
It's kind of complicated
and expensive,
but it was the only
way we could get chunks
that were what we wanted.
So that's how the chunks or
how the dots, if they became
three-dimensional would
relate to the smoke rings
when they became
three-dimensional.
So that's a whole other problem
that's either ahead of us
or, maybe, become forgotten.
I don't know.
But that's another
possibility compared
to the way we're doing it,
which is in a relatively
conventional and flat way.
Basically, the painting
represents the drawings
printed on paper and cut out.
These paintings, including
the one that's upstairs,
are basically paintings that
have some illusion in them,
but it's the illusion of a
collage of cut pieces of paper
that are then enlarged.
So that's the piece
that's upstairs
when it was in the [INAUDIBLE]
Gallery on the right.
And then these are flat pieces.
This is in the Kawamura
Museum in Japan,
and that's when
we were conceiving
of the pieces as kind
of installed murals
to relate to the actual
space that was there.
And this is what it, as
they say, turns out to be.
On the one hand is a painting
by a graffiti artist,
and the other hand is
a painting of mine.
In the end, they're
not that different,
but it's a way of making
the thing sort of move.
The issue here, for me anyway--
I'm not sure what the
issue was for him--
but it was to make it move out.
And one of the problems
with the graffiti-- not
that I think that that's either
a good or a bad painting.
I don't think it's either
one, but it can be very good.
But one of the problems
with it is that--
and it's the same thing
that happens with me--
which is that you're forced
to make it on a canvas,
so it has a boundary,
and it's a convention.
So it's forced to
become a painting.
The painting on the graffiti
was put in a gallery,
and this kid who's perfectly
capable of handling a spray
can with a lot of effect--
it would be better on metal or
on the side of a moving subway
car than it is on canvas when it
stops moving, when it's static.
And there's the
same problem I have,
because it's just on a canvas.
I make it move as much as I can.
I do all kinds of things.
But in a way, I'm not
that satisfied with it.
Although I like it optically--
I mean, I like it as illusion.
But again, I'm still torn.
I'd like it to be literal too.
And this was the beginning of
the idea on a public scale.
This is just painting
outside on the back
of a theater in Toronto, the
Princess of Wales Theatre.
And then we'll see
the inside now.
This was the start for
one reason or another,
and it's the painting on the--
that's, I think, a
quarter [INAUDIBLE]..
I'm pretty sure that's
what it is, anyway.
But the thing about
it is that it works.
When we looked at the paintings
before the graffiti painting
and my painting, they had
the conventional boundaries.
There's something about the
imagery, the smoke rings--
I mean, I guess it's
a little bit obvious.
But anyway, the fact that the
circular shape and the moving
around does the
boundaries, which
are the top and
the bottom of that,
don't seem to press
themselves on you in the way
that they normally would.
The fact that there
are no side edges,
that the imagery keeps moving
and keeps circulating, I think,
is a tremendous plus.
That's some detail.
And then these are
the balcony fronts.
And what's interesting about
those, I think, in some ways,
is that they're
totally abstract.
There's some of the
computer imagery.
There's some of the forms that,
actually, you'll see later
in some of the other things.
We used everything that we used,
and we just made it in relief,
and then cast it.
And the result was it looked
very ordinary, actually.
Very un-abstract
and very much like
a floral decorative design,
maybe, from the 18th century.
But the big plus was it was
acoustically very successful.
MITCHELL: Where is this?
STELLA: It's in Toronto
in a theater called
the Princess of Wales Theatre,
which was a new theater built,
actually, for Miss Saigon.
And now, Beauty and
the Beast is there.
[LAUGHTER]
MITCHELL: This is cast aluminum?
STELLA: Yeah.
This is cast aluminum.
The same idea.
Like, the other things
were cast plaster.
And then this is part of the
theater downstairs in a--
I don't know.
Not a restaurant, but I
don't know if it's a bar.
You can see that the
architecture is not
exactly flattering, but
you can still carry it.
And one of the advantages
of this kind of imagery
and this way of
dealing with things
is you can sort of fight your
way through almost anything.
These are big
murals in the lobby,
and they look nice
in the photographs,
actually, in the slides.
They're not so red
hot when you see them.
[LAUGHTER]
They're painted with the most
modern billboard technology
available.
There's a transparency
that's read and then scanned,
and then it's sprayed with
four-colored dots on plastic.
But it's super durable,
and the machine
can paint that mural in about,
I don't know, 80 or 90 hours.
It goes night and day, and then
it's done in a couple of days.
Well, for those of you who
are architects, I'm sure
you'll love these.
[LAUGHS]
These are the drawings
that we made after we built
the piece that's upstairs.
And we made these drawings
for a gallery exhibition,
which actually is going to
open next week in New York.
And the reason that
we did it is that we
wanted to try out
the idea, and we
wanted to do what we couldn't
do upstairs, which is to paint
on both sides of the surface.
So these a freestanding
sort of murals,
and they will be
painted on both sides.
And because we designed it
right into the computer,
we're able to have
it carved directly.
So the technology, the
fittings, and everything,
it's much smoother
and much nicer
than the piece that's upstairs,
although I'm not trying
to denigrate that in any way.
But we've made a
technological advance
since that piece was done.
MITCHELL: What's the
material for this?
STELLA: It's fiberglass.
It's really a big surfboard.
I mean, it's the wave
and the surfboard.
I guess it's the whole thing.
But it's just really
literally a big surfboard,
and it's cut into
sections, and they fit,
and it's pretty smooth.
There are a couple of
pictures of it later on.
MITCHELL: What kind
of building machine--
a three-axis, a nine-axis?
STELLA: I don't know.
It just works.
I'll check.
It's pretty sophisticated.
I don't know if it has that.
We can go through these.
I mean, maybe some
people like these.
Anyway, that's what we do.
Okay.
Next.
But again, they stand up.
So it's pretty simple.
It's a rectangle on the
bottom and a wavy line drawn
on the top, and then
you connect the surfaces
like a minimal surface.
And that's what it looks
like when it's being done.
That's the studio, and
that's those things.
And you can see that it
looks like a surfboard
there in the corner,
and it's pretty good.
It's pretty smooth, and
it's easy to work on.
Okay.
There are a few more shots.
It's mostly masking tape.
And you can see how
to paint while you're
talking on the telephone.
[LAUGHTER]
You learn a lot from
looking at these.
And this is the last idea.
This is when you take an idea,
and you give it to an engineer.
The idea is pretty simple.
It was a beach hat that
my kids got for me in Rio.
And it's a piece of foam,
and there are spirals
cut out of the center.
They're just cut.
So it's really cuts in
a two-dimensional plane,
but it's a beautiful form
for twisting once you cut it.
Almost anything you do with
it looks great, so let's
see what we do with it.
That's the same form.
And this is being
built now in Antibes.
We tried to build it in America,
but it was too expensive,
and they didn't want to do it.
Well, we found some boat
builders in Antibes,
we found a naval architect
to help us with it.
And what's interesting
about it is
that it's exactly the same
from a technical point of view.
It's exactly the
same as the model.
The model is a small piece
of plastic [INAUDIBLE]..
It's cut out, and
that's bent and twisted.
And so we convinced these
guys to just work for us
for a few months.
And they laid out
fiberglass on the floor,
and they made the sheet.
So the sheet was made with
a diameter of about 24 feet.
And then the cuts were made,
and then they bent that,
and then they laminated
balsa wood to that,
and then laminated the other
surface, and then took the cut.
So they literally
made it the hard way,
but it's actually the only way
that you can get the forms--
that I know of any way--
that are this complicated
and within some
kind of reasonable
kind of expense.
The reason we had to
go to this trouble
was that it has to be suspended.
And it's in a place
that's aluminum and glass
and can't take much
of a load, so we
had to be under 6,000 pounds.
It's roughly a 20,
24 foot diameter.
And this is the same form
seen in two different computer
renditions of the same idea
used to make a building rather
than just a sculpture.
And I think that might be it.
I don't know if there's
any more slides.
MITCHELL: Nothing's
on the slider.
Maybe we can put
the lights on, and I
suspect that various
people may have
questions they'd like to raise.
STELLA: Okay.
AUDIENCE: When you say
move [INAUDIBLE] the mural.
You were talking about
trying to get it to move.
I was wondering if you can
explain, maybe, what you mean.
Move in what way?
I wasn't sure, because
a subway car moves
in a certain kind
of way, but I'm not
sure that's what you meant.
STELLA: Well, the subway car
is pretty straightforward.
It just moves by you and
depending on the speed.
But it's not so important
what actually the movement is.
It could move sideways, it
could go this way, up and down,
and back and forth.
But it's the sense of movement.
I mean, most paintings
that are successful
or most paintings that you care
about have a sense of movement.
By definition, painting
has a serious--
and it's one of the things
that comes up nowadays
with literalism--
is painting is static.
It doesn't move.
And almost anybody can
make a painting that moves
or make an object that moves.
And one of the
reasons why film is
so popular, it can
make a claim to being
more advanced or better than
painting, because it moves,
it flickers, and it's better
at depicting movement.
These things are all relative,
but they're important.
And I think that the success
of painting in the past,
which is why bring up the notion
or the problem of illusionism,
has been a success at being
a static art that implies
movement in a convincing way.
I don't want to play with
words, but the literal movement
within the picture,
the action, whatever
is depicted that takes place and
the emotional substance of it,
you are moved in a way too.
But I think that they
have to come together.
When we say a painting
is great, that's really
what we're talking about.
It seems vital to
us, and there's
a kind of movement in
an unreal situation.
After all, it's static.
And at the same
time, we are moved.
The interior, our interior, our
consciousness, our feelings,
and everything are moved.
So there's these two kinds
of movement, neither of which
are quantifiable in any way.
I mean, you can't really
very well describe
or it doesn't mean much
to say, I feel this,
or I feel that,
because how do you know
what the other person knows?
He doesn't really know very
much about what you feel
or what it means to feel.
You can say, I feel sad, but
these are not very exacting.
And it's the same
way about the sense
of how successful the
movement is within a picture.
But these things
still, nonetheless,
as difficult as they
are to deal with it,
it seems, to me
anyway, pretty clear
that they are what painting
both is and is about.
Well, that was a short answer.
Sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Could you tell
us a little bit more
of the title Loohooloo?
And also I know there is
a new biography coming out
on you by Guberman, and how--
STELLA: Well, you
all know the answer.
I can tell you that.
[LAUGHTER]
I can guarantee that.
However, there's a person
sitting four rows back
here who's are
expert on Melville,
but the title comes
from a Melville novel
which I haven't read.
[LAUGHTER]
And I make no apologies.
In fact, when we went to
a Melville symposium--
we all live in our own
little worlds, as they say.
But a woman came up to me and
was so happy that I had done--
she expected me to
do for Melville,
for Marty, for what
I'd done for Moby Dick.
I mean, I just spent five
years working on Moby Dick,
and she wanted me to
spend another five or six
years working on Marty to
see if I could resurrect it,
because she felt it was a
very under-appreciated effort.
But that wasn't my goal, and
it's not going to be my goal.
AUDIENCE: Do you ever seen
an error of cooperation
between artists and architects
similar to [INAUDIBLE]??
STELLA: Well, I don't think so.
[LAUGHS]
My experience with architects
has been pretty grim.
[LAUGHTER]
But I think yes.
I think it's possible.
Basically, you get the
job after the architect
has done what he's done.
And so if I want to work with
an architect, I'll hire him,
but I can make the billing.
You could cooperate.
But the problems are nothing
is very conducive to it.
The whole scheme for building
is so obvious and so complicated
at the same time
that there really--
the main problem is not just for
the architects and the artists
working together.
It's really a problem
for the architects too.
Few, if any, architects that
I know of in recent time--
and Frank Gehry tries
it once in a while--
are able to change anything.
In other words, you're
committed to a building scheme
after the plan's in.
That's it.
It's over.
You can see what
mistakes you made,
but you can't do anything
about it, and nothing changes.
Gaudi is the last
one I can think of.
Nervi was pretty good at it.
But Gaudi, Nervi, those
people could make things
happen and make things change.
Corbusier did it in some
of the houses I think too.
Architects are no different
from anybody else.
They don't get it all right the
first time, as we well know.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
There seems to be more interest
amongst artists dealing with
murals or site-specific
works than the other way--
architecture [INAUDIBLE].
STELLA: I don't know.
It probably is.
It's probably true that way.
But it's a small world, and
there's a lot of building,
and there are a few architects
who have a sense of themselves,
and what they can do,
and what art's about that
maybe only a few architects can
really afford to bring people
in to do the jobs.
There isn't much
left in the budget.
Most of the work that
gets done, as we all know,
is from the few jobs
that are mandated.
The budget mandates
some decoration or art.
And I've yet to meet
an architect who
didn't complain about that too.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Can I ask you to
explore that a bit more?
Also the issues of
scale-- the beach towel
that looks good at the
scale of a couple of feet,
and then becomes a sculpted
form in tens of feet.
And then it becomes a building,
and it's 200 feet scale.
Going from that painting to a
sculpted form to architecture.
It seems to me that
sometimes a form
becomes pretty intimidating
when it becomes a building
or it becomes architecture.
STELLA: I made a building
for the project--
I didn't have it
here for Dresden--
and Phillip Johnson built it
in his gatehouse in New Canaan.
And it was a
monstrous masterpiece,
but it was only the
shell of what we did.
We never worked on a
fenestration or the roof,
or anything like that.
But the form, he was able
to build it and blow it up.
It seemed to work okay.
AUDIENCE: I'd just like to ask
a question about [INAUDIBLE],,
because I recall, for
example, in the question
in the panorama, where
they would rotate
the stage [INAUDIBLE]
developed to the various forms
of the panorama.
STELLA: In Mississippi
and Missouri.
Well the painting-- Yeah.
The painting didn't move--
I mean, the painting moved
as you rolled up one end
and unrolled the other,
and you moved it across.
AUDIENCE: What
type-- the audience
rotated in the sense
of-- of course,
if you go into a
gallery, you're moving
so the painting [INAUDIBLE].
You're getting movement,
so [INAUDIBLE]..
STELLA: Okay.
But it's still--
I don't know.
There are a lot of
ways of looking at it.
But the basic thing
is you make a mark.
You act, and you make a mark.
And that's it.
It stays there.
It doesn't move after you--
you can't keep the paint
moving after it dries.
That's it.
I mean, you could.
You could make it
slippery there.
There are a lot of things
you could do, but it's not--
it would be both
complicated and difficult.
Although you see a lot of that
in installations and stuff.
I remember Bob Rauschenberg did
a piece for art and technology
which was a big, steel box
with mud and hot water in it
and the bubbling mud.
[LAUGHTER]
It wasn't bad.
And it was certainly good.
As an idea, it sounds
better than it looked.
I mean, you get tired
of the bubbling.
[LAUGHTER]
But you know that you can say
that paintings get tiring,
but it just raises the issue.
I mean, it's a good
way of seeing it.
The point about painting
is painting also has a past
and has a history.
I don't know if it's the
convention that we accept
and that we like, or
they really did it right.
Sometimes it happens in the
right way, and it's convincing,
and it's okay.
And then when you
bring up the issue
like having the
boiling mud, it's
sort of interesting
to bring up the issue,
and it gets your attention.
But does it carry, and
does it hold as much
as the non-bubbling
works like that?
AUDIENCE: I noticed
in working space.
You're very interested
in Caravaggio.
And now we see these frescoes
in palaces, and churches,
and things like this, in the
theater in Toronto, where you
enter, the building decoration.
Do you find that you end up
wishing that things looked more
like they did in the
1600s, say, instead
of the clean, modernist
look from, say, 10-250?
[LAUGHTER]
STELLA: What's 10-250.
MITCHELL: This room.
STELLA: Oh, this room?
MITCHELL: Yeah.
STELLA: Oh.
I'm not sure.
What was the point, though?
What does Caravaggio
have to do with it?
AUDIENCE: Go back
to that period a lot
and refer to it as
sort of [INAUDIBLE]..
STELLA: Yeah.
The reasons for
Caravaggio are different
from the general reason,
which is the Baroque.
The reason I was drawn
to it or interested in it
was a matter of change
in my working life,
as it were, for 10 to 15 years.
Making things, quote
"literal, direct, and simple"
seemed to have a
tremendous virtue.
And I didn't find it convincing,
and it's nice to look to some.
It wasn't just what
everybody said.
It wasn't all that great.
And it wasn't, but I don't
think that's as important
as it wasn't going anywhere.
And I'm not saying that this
way of working or anything
is necessarily going anywhere.
It is different, and to me
anyway, the painting in itself
and the way it relates
to both the architecture
and the sculpture
seems to me, anyway,
a pretty fruitful
way of working.
And if I look at what I've
done and what I'm doing,
I have to say, well, it
may not be that great,
but it's not boring me to death.
MITCHELL: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
One has to do with
transformation
from the gray
values to the color?
Because [INAUDIBLE] gray
value [INAUDIBLE] to color,
and I was wondering
how you did that.
And two, I was wondering how
the smoke was-- actually,
it moved vertically.
And at least the piece that we
had here had two [INAUDIBLE],,
and it's actually [INAUDIBLE].
It moves in and out
but not up and down.
I was curious about
that-- those two things.
STELLA: I'm not sure
exactly what you're saying,
but one of the things is true.
One of the senses that
there's no way of getting,
which is really beautiful
about the smoke,
is that, first of all,
it goes in the direction
that you send it.
But then when it
hovers, when it stops,
it then creates its own
sense of dropping out.
And as it drops,
it forms, again,
depending on all kinds of
things like the temperature,
and currents, and air currents.
And that has its own kind of
really compelling dynamism,
which I like.
I'm not going to get
that in the painting.
I'm not worried about.
But the idea is that
maybe, in some way, which
is not that clear,
one way or the other,
I get something like that.
That's what I'm
going to settle for,
and I'll be quite happy
if I get a little closer.
AUDIENCE: Can you
describe your methods
of working with assistants?
What do they do,
what did they do,
and how do you feel about it?
STELLA: Well, I can
tell you what they feel.
They feel they do everything.
[LAUGHTER]
And I--
MITCHELL: They keep
working on the photo.
STELLA: Right, right, right.
And I make a mess of all
their really good ideas,
but you have to learn
to live with it.
[LAUGHTER]
They all are
tremendously talented,
they do a really good job,
and they do things I can't do.
And they have a
lot of good ideas,
but I like some of my ideas too.
You just work it out.
You just keep banging away.
The biggest thing-- the
only reason that they stay
is because of the opportunities.
Because we do work on new
ideas, there are things to do,
and they can get to
run off by themselves
and do what they want to do
that they couldn't do otherwise.
But if it weren't for that,
they would be long gone.
I guarantee you.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'm curious about
these sculptural forms
that you're working with
now, from the last few slides
that you showed.
And they seem very compelling
forms, but in the slides,
they weren't yet painted.
One of them was turned
into architecture.
[INAUDIBLE]
STELLA: The one
that was painted was
the way it's supposed to
be, as far as I'm concerned.
The client would like
it to be more colorful.
His decorator, his
color consultant,
told him that it should
be gold with pastel tints.
[LAUGHTER]
But we made it white
with color on the edges.
And Kevin Roach said--
he made me swear on the Bible
that it could only be white.
I couldn't ruin the
space and everything.
It just can't have
color in there.
It just has to be pure white.
And I said, fine.
I want it to be white.
So then the client comes
in, and he says, you know,
Kevin says it really should
be very colorful there.
[LAUGHTER]
So anyway, it's a compromise.
It has color on the edges
and white on 80% of it.
But the form-- that
piece should be white.
I don't know.
I mean, I could work on it
more, and I probably will.
The color on the edges
is not the wrong idea.
It's just it's not that
easy to get it right
and get it to
Singapore in 20 days.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: With some of these
forms, you made the form.
And then you then paint.
STELLA: Right.
But that form, it
could be in a painting,
or it could be a relief,
or something like that.
But right now, that form seems
to be pretty straightforward.
It's a sculptural
form, and it works.
I think it's
tremendous, and I think
it'll work as an
architectural form too.
I mean, I know it will.
It's just a question
of the expense.
Building it architecturally
is difficult,
but the real
problem is not that.
The forms could be
built. If it were
for a bandshell
in Rio de Janeiro,
you could build
it in 10 minutes.
But if you're going to
put it in Bangor, Maine,
you've got to seal it.
It's got to be weather tight.
It's a pretty severe test
for those kind of forms.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about your values
in the diagram on
the blackboard.
It seems to me, especially
in the Phillip piece,
boundaries are, in fact,
part of the illusion
in the room, that you have the
actual, physical boundaries
of the four sides to the walls
and that the painting then
actually starts to create
this illusion of where
the boundaries are.
So is, in fact,
boundaries just as much
a part of the illusion
as the surface is
and not part of the [INAUDIBLE]?
STELLA: I'm with
you 100%, or 150%.
That, I think, is the point
that I most wanted to make.
It's the relation of
the things to each other
and their ability to
expand and to form in a way
as something else to change
the space, to change things,
to change your perception of
it and how you feel about it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STELLA: Well, some of
those paintings I showed
were paintings on
flat surfaces, and I
think they were pretty good.
But they have a problem
that they are not
so good unless they
have a lot of shadow,
a lot of illusionism.
And the trompe l'oeil is
sort of against my religion,
so it's a real conflict.
So it was a way of doing
it, and getting the idea,
and seeing what it
does, but I don't think
that I would be happy with it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STELLA: Well, I
like to think that--
I mean, you can't
nail everything down,
but I'm not seeking
ambiguity for its own sake.
There's sometimes
things seem ambiguous,
and sometimes that's a plus.
But it's not a goal, and
neither really is complexity.
But ambiguity and
complexity-- and I
don't think I was
going to say-- are
pretty necessary ingredients.
So the question is to deal
with them and have them.
That's the job.
That's where the
art part comes in.
You have to pull it together.
MITCHELL: Let's take one more.
STELLA: Okay.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: You using the computer
a lot in transformations.
Does the computer gives
you an opportunity
to generate continual movement?
STELLA: Not the ones
that I can afford.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: You've been spending
sabbatical at MIT for a while,
and there are [INAUDIBLE].
Have you thought of actually
constructing the artwork
on the computer, or
do you consider it
only a tool for the use in
constructing [INAUDIBLE]??
STELLA: Yeah.
I see it only as
a tool, and I only
really like one
thing about it, which
is the most simple
and obvious thing--
the ability to rotate the thing
in space and to really sort of
move it around.
The stretching, and pulling,
and all the complicated things
you can do with it, I can do
that with the model anyway,
and I can even turn the model.
But it's nice to
be able to see it.
It's a very useful tool.
I was very unhappy
with my experience.
The reason we started using
a computer in the first place
was to help us build things, and
that was a complete disaster.
It's worthless as a tool for
building anything, at least
on the level that
you can afford.
So I don't know.
You can build anything
you want using a computer.
If you build it, make one
thing, it costs a fortune.
And if you do that
10,000 or 150,000 times,
it's a perfectly useful tool.
But for doing it once, and
changing it immediately,
and doing something
different, it's a nightmare.
But also, as I've talked
about with some other people,
the issues--
I mean, the thing that I'm
interested in, I suppose,
is what a lot of other
people are interested in.
The smoke, certainly, I'd
like to put on the computer
and then see how it would
change under conditions of heat,
wind, humidity, and whatnot.
If you know a way to do
it, you can let me know.
Since it's all particles, it's
kind of expensive to map them
or whatever you do on the
computer, put them out.
MITCHELL: We'll
just take two more.
STELLA: Okay.
AUDIENCE: Your most
recent work seems
to be on the verge of movement.
What is your feeling about
kinetic [INAUDIBLE],, which
was done a long time ago, and it
is still being done by others?
STELLA: No.
I don't have anything
against kinetic art,
but one of the
problems with it is
it's the problem of literalism.
It is what it is, and
it does what it does.
And it tends to
lack a kind of magic
that seems to be
inherent in illusionism.
But I don't have
anything against it.
In fact, I own some.
I think it's possible.
There are a lot of
things you could do.
But one of the problems--
from a practical point
of view, movement
is a difficult
problem, because it's
a question of how much
you want to program,
and how much you
want to control,
and then what you want it to do,
But look, it's possible.
I think that it's
going to happen.
There's going to be more of
it, and maybe it'll be better.
MITCHELL: We'll take
a last question here.
AUDIENCE: I've been thinking,
is one of the main things
[INAUDIBLE] surfaces.
But the thing that you do
paint on fixed surfaces,
those are not going
to move at all.
But on the other hand
you have the [INAUDIBLE],,
for I do say, for instance, the
artwork of mud with bubbles.
But there are compromises,
like, for instance,
painting on flexible
surfaces, such as [INAUDIBLE]..
STELLA: Yeah.
We tried to build a
building with Teflon,
and they got hysterical.
[LAUGHTER]
But lots of other people do it.
Look, I think it's
perfectly possible.
AUDIENCE: This one I
think is [INAUDIBLE]..
STELLA: Yeah.
I love-- I mean, I wanted
to use mirrored mylar too.
There are a lot of
materials out there.
things that you can do.
But then the question becomes
how do you program or control
the movement.
What's the movement going to be?
Is it going to flutter
in the breeze or not?
What's the movement?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STELLA: Okay.
Maybe there's a confusion--
not a confusion.
I mean, it's my own
fault, but it's okay.
Movement is one thing, okay?
And so it's literal movement.
It does this, or it does that.
But the heart of the matter
is not as much the movement
as it is the action.
It's what's depicted,
it's what's happening,
and it's what makes
painting great.
Whether it's abstract
or real is how
you perceive that, how you
relate to that, to the action,
to the movement, to the kind
of movement that it is, how
it's informed, what it's doing.
It's not just the movement.
I mean, the movement is
a way of describing it,
but it's really
basically the action,
which is the action, the
subject, or whatever it is.
MITCHELL: There's no way
to summarize all of this
if we're just going
through, but let me ask--
STELLA: Let me try.
Go ahead.
[LAUGHTER]
MITCHELL: I'm not.
Even for an academic, I'm not
so foolish as to try that.
But what I would
like to do is ask
you one final, broad question.
Where do you go from here?
What do you see as the most
exciting things to explore,
and what are the ideas
that really animate you
right now for you?
STELLA: Well, the hardest thing
and the most interesting thing
to me is to keep going on all,
as I described before-- which
was the point of the diagrams
and everything-- which
was to deal with fine
art as an enterprise
and to be able to work.
But it's hard to be able
to work, or to afford,
or whatever you want to say,
and also in terms of energy
as well as all the
other things to see--
to keep working on, basically,
the three areas, more or less,
at the same time and to
see where it gets me.
I guess what I want
to say is I don't
want to drop any one of
the three in particular.
And it doesn't matter to me
about architecture if I don't--
if I have to see
Phillip's version of it.
But it's just to keep
working on the ideas,
on the models, and the
projects, and to keeps thinking
about it I guess.
MITCHELL: All right.
Thank you.
Thank you, Frank Stella.
[APPLAUSE]